said his challenge started in November
or users were able to submit ideas
online five winners were selected voted
on by the public that submitted ideas of
what they would do with Toyota
technology if they repurposed it we're
gonna build real working prototypes of
each of these five layers ideas nathan
has been a great force and pittsburgh
for innovation for a while now and here
pushed me and said you know Toyota has
this great project what if we could
actually realize the ideas so what if
people could dream up ideas around the
world and we were able to actually make
prototypes of those ideas that work
right here in a weekend Carnegie Mellon
is is the perfect place to imagine the
perfect society where people with
completely different disciplines all
come together for crazy ideas work it
out in the weekend and then split up and
do something else with some other group
of people
next week the reason you want to make
things physical or you want to really
make things real is ideas are everywhere
ideas are in our heads well when you
take an idea into the physical world you
make it real or you model it or you
prototype it what you're gonna do is
you're gonna start to learn a lot more
about it you can learn a lot of the
things that you might otherwise take for
granted Carnegie Mellon has a worldwide
reputation as an ideation kind of
environment they inspire their students
we're going to continue to support CMU
in their endeavors so they can continue
to take some of these ideas or other
ideas and turn them into useful products
or services for society Carnegie Mellon
to come to the home
the ideas move over the university can
give these ideas to the students and see
if they can take it one step further and
our dream is to think the most promising
ideas work with experts around the world
and think about how we can mature them
as much as possible into something
that's of real value to society